Chevrolet is bringing a new off-roader
to Europe the Trax is the latest in a
long line of Chevy SUVs back in 1935 the
suburban carry all became the first ever
sports utility vehicle
78 years on we take its youngest
descendant out for a test run
I noticed doing something most people
don't do with their cars taking it
offroad
so why do people buy as Uli's because
you sit higher up and have a better view
plus they're practical in the tracks you
can fold over the front passenger seat
armrest so you can fit in shelves up to
2 meters 30 long Nick's Piazza Mubarak
tendon pass near the gala line read on a
maximum length on distance why meet at I
see the tracks is based on the GM gamma2
platform which is shared with the Opel
Mokka the seats can be folded down
easily increasing the cargo capacity to
1370 liters instead of shelves however
we're loading in a life-sized picture of
a basketball player
Chevalier stood the mark he stands for
affordable vehicles sound design
dependability and functionality says
Chevrolet Germany's managing director
and the Trax is a good example you
immediately notice the unmistakable
design and a sporting one at that
there's the large radiator grille with a
Chevrolet logo in the middle the Trax
measures 1 meter 70 by 4 meters 20
clearly compact for an SUV and you
notice that on the inside too
the interior is tidy and clearly
structured as a driver you find
everything you need quickly enough among
the optional extras is the MyLink
infotainment system which links up your
smartphone to the tracks via bluetooth
or USB connection as well as music it
also delivers navigation data the system
is operated using buttons on the
steering wheel and a touchpad the Trax
comes with a choice of three engines we
tested the most powerful a 1.7 liter
diesel unit with 96 kilowatts of power
the manufacturer claims fuel consumption
of 4.9 liters for 100 kilometers that's
not a bad staff for an SUV of this size
detects Athens ELLs the tracks is a very
balanced ride which is not that normal
for SUVs because of their higher
position racing cars are extremely low
in order to maximize road-holding making
a car higher is a problem for the
chassis and the overall balance but the
tracks manages that wonderfully demo no
secrets of life that's club amtrak saba
Vinoba the entry-level model with a 1.6
liter gasoline engine goes on sale in
germany for just under 17,000 euros the
top-level version we tested cost twenty
six thousand euros so what does our
reviewer reckon
tetrax inode was impressed by the
Traxxas handling an agile engines both
diesel and gasoline as it clearly laid
out a very spacious interior with a
maximum cargo capacity of 1,000 370
liters and a 2 meters 30 maximum loading
length that's always a plus even if you
don't need to transport a basketballer
every day
you